no I don't think we're passed a tipping
point because you'd have to define
tipping point I mean I would define
tipping point as obliteration of
civilization I don't think we're there
we're still here but I think we're
playing with some loaded guns you know
there's people that are routinely now
talking about will culture survive this
millennium this hundred years will
culture actually exist there's
scientists in the last couple days that
I've interacted with that have talked
about the entire polar ice cap the
Arctic ice cap melting within 35 years
everything everything and you're
starting to see all those signs with you
know Russian subs and everything else
and people are starting say okay who's
who oh this water and everything else so
it's going to throw off an entire set of
other things in China a lot of the
glaciers that actually contribute to the
jet streams and define all the jet
streams are all being melted so it's a
big issue it will impact everyone I
think outside of wars which would also
be promoted by this kind of instability
you know our civilization can adapt for
a while we're going to have to that's
that's the cards that we have and it's
the cards that we're leaving our kids
but it's not going to be easy and
hopefully there won't be any wars that
drag things into other categories
I'm not concern to like screaming you
know bandwidth i would say that we
should be seriously concerned almost
nearing the urgent and crisis mode and
it's hard to do that because you turn
the TV on and you see some insipid drama
about some movie stars stupid habit and
you missed the long term you miss what's
really happening honestly i turned my TV
off a decade ago and i haven't missed
anything you want to see a good film
netflix we are so bogged down by inane
stupid details that we're missing the
biggest story
you